>>> THE COAST GUARD HAS BEEN
HARD AT WORK, TRYING TO REACH
PEOPLE IN SOME OF THE
HARDEST-HIT AREAS.
SANIBEL ISLAND WAS ONE OF THEM,
AS HURRICANE IAN PRETTY MUCH
LEFT THE ISLAND CUT OFF FROM THE
MAINLAND.
IT WASHED AWAY A SECTION OF THE
SANIBEL CAUSEWAY
.
>> HOW MANY OF THERE ARE YOU?
>> ME AND MY WIFE.
>> DO YOU HAVE A BAG OR
SOMETHING?
>> OKAY.
WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
>> IF YOU GUYS CAN MAKE IT OUT
THE WINDOW, YOU CAN COME THIS
WAY.
MAKE SURE YOU HAVE A BAG WITH A
DRY PAIR OF CLOTHES, WITH I.D.s,
CELL PHONES, WALLETS.
ALL RIGHT?
WE'RE GOING TO GET -- THERE'S A
WHOLE BUNCH OF PEOPLE JUST LIKE
Y'ALL.
THOUSANDS OF THEM.
TAKE YOU TO A SHELTER WHERE
YOU'LL BE ALL RIGHT.
YOU'LL HAVE FOOD AND WATER AND
EVERYTHING.
>> THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GO, ARE
THEY?
>> EVERYBODY ELSE IS STAYING.
THEY DON'T WANT TO GO, SO WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP ON GOING.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE LOUD AND
YOU'LL BE A LITTLE COLD IN THE
WATER, BUT WE'LL TAKE YOU TO THE
CHOPPER.
IT'S ABOUT TEN MINUTES IN THE
YOU'LL BE OKAY.
>>
>> YOU'RE GOING TO GET A LITTLE
WET.
THE COAST GUARD HAS BEEN TRYING
TO REACH PEOPLE ON SANIBEL
ISLAND WHO HAVE BEEN CUT OFF
FROM THE MAIN LAPD AFTER THE
STORM SURGE HIT SO MUCH OF THAT
ISLAND.
AND WASHED AWAY PARTS OF THE
SANIBEL CAUSEWAY.
SO YOU CAN'T DRIVE TO SANIBEL
ANYMORE.
WITH ME NOW IS REAR ADMIRAL
BRENDAN McPHERSON.
HE'S THE COMMANDER OF THE
SEVENTH COAST GUARD DISTRICT.
ADMIRAL, THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US.
LET ME FIRST ASK YOU ABOUT THE
NOW.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING NOW?
HOW MUCH NEED IS THERE TO REACH
PEOPLE THIS MORNING?
>> YEAH, GOOD MORNING, JOHN.
IT WAS A BUSY DAY OF SEARCH AND
RESCUE FOR THE COAST GUARD
YESTERDAY.
WE HAD 16 AIRCRAFT UP IN THE AIR
THROUGHOUT THE DAY AND
OVERNIGHT.
WE WERE ABLE TO RESCUE 95
PEOPLE.
AND WE'RE STARTING GET AT FIRST
LIGHT THIS MORNING.
WE'VE GOT OUR AIRCRAFT IN THE
AIR THIS MORNING.
WE'RE GOING TO GET OUT THERE.
WE'RE GOING TO FIND ANYBODY ELSE
THAT NEEDS ASSISTANCE.
>> SO 95 RESCUES YESTERDAY.
AND SOME OF THE PLACES, WE
SHOULD NOTE, WE TALKED ABOUT
SANIBEL, THE ONLY WAY TO GET
THERE WAS BY HELICOPTER.
YOU'RE THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO COULD
REACH THE FOLKS ON THAT ISLAND.
DESCRIBE THE TYPES OF RESCUES
THAT WERE GOING ON.
>> YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT, JOHN.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS AN ALL-HANDS
EFFORT.
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE FLORIDA
NATIONAL GUARD AND FEMA, URBAN
SEARCH AND RESCUE TEAMS, ALONG
WITH THE LOCAL RESPONDERS YOU
SEE THERE.
BUT IN SOME CASES, LIKE IN
SANIBEL, CAPTIVA AND OTHER AREAS
THAT ARE COMPLETELY SHUT OFF,
THE ONLY WAY TO GET THERE IS BY
HELICOPTER.
OUR COAST GUARD HELICOPTERS WITH
THEIR AIR CREWS ARE GETTING IN
THERE.
WE'RE LOWERING OUR RESCUE
SWIMMERS, CHECKING ON PEOPLE,
AND IF THEY NEED PULLING OUT,
WE'RE PULLING OUT.
NOT ONLY ARE WE SAVING PEOPLE,
WE WERE ABLE TO RESCUE TEN DOGS,
EIGHT CATS, AND ONE BIRD
YESTERDAY, AS WELL.
>> TEN DOGS, EIGHT CATS, AND ONE
BIRD.
ADMIRAL, THAT IS SOMETHING.
AGAIN, YOU SAY YOU'RE OUT THERE
READY TO GO, READY TO HELP
PEOPLE.
ARE THERE CALLS COMING IN?
WHAT IS THE PROCESS?
DO PEOPLE CALL, CONTACT YOU, OR
DO YOU JUST SPOT FOLKS FROM THE
SKY?
>> YEAH, JOHN, THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF BOTH.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, IF SOMEBODY
IS IN DISTRESS, THEY NEED
ASSISTANCE, CALL 911.
THAT IS THE BEST WAY TO REACH
FIRST RESPONDERS.
WE'LL GET THAT CALL DISPATCHED
TO US IF THEY NEED A HELICOPTER.
BUT WE'VE ALSO GOT GROUND TEAMS
THERE.
WE'VE GOT BOATS IN THE WATER,
SHALLOW WATER BOATS.
THE COAST GUARD HAS SHALLOW
WATER RESCUE BOATS WORKING WITH
OUR URBAN SEARCH AND RESCUE
TEAMS.
THAT'S THE BEST WAY TO DO IT.
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE, NOT EVERYBODY
HAS COMMUNICATIONS.
WE'RE ACTUALLY FLYING AROUND,
SPOTTING PEOPLE.
AND THEN RESPONDING TO THEIR
DISTRESS.
IT'S REALLY, THINK OF IT MORE
LIKE A MILITARY OPERATION.
WE'VE GOT THE WHOLE AREA GRIDDED
OUT AND WE'RE SEARCHING
GRID-TO-GRID, BOX-BY-BOX, TO SEE
IF ANYBODY NEEDS ASSISTANCE.
>> AND WHAT DO YOU HEAR FROM THE
PEOPLE THAT YOU DO SAVE?
>> WELL, JOHN, THEY'RE VERY
GRATEFUL.
OUR HEART GOES OUT TO ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE IMPACTED BY
THIS.
IT'S A DEVASTATING STORM.
YOU'RE THERE, YOU'VE SEEN IT
YOURSELF.
AND SO WE WANT TO BRING THEM
COMFORT AND SAFETY.
AND THEN WE'LL GET TO THE
LONG-TERM RECOVERY.
SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING ELSE
WE'RE FOCUSED ON.
WE'RE READY FOR THE SECOND FRONT
OF THIS TWO-FRONT WAR.
AS YOU INDICATED, THIS HURRICANE
IAN IS NOT DONE WITH US YET.
SHE'S SCHEDULED TO MAKE LANDFALL
LATER TODAY IN THE CHARLESTON,
SOUTH CAROLINA, AREA.
SO WE'VE GOT COASTGUARD FORCES
THERE, TOO, READY TO RESPOND,
SHOULD THEY BE NEEDED.
>> WE KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO BE
THERE.
WE KNOW YOU'LL BE WHEREVER THERE
IS NEED.
REAR ADMIRAL BRENDAN McPHERSON,
THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
THIS MORNING.
>> THANKS, JOHN.